behind-the-scenes like below zero is how
we make the show right here we travel
light for this show I'd probably say
it's close to fifty pieces a lot of
people understand there's so much travel
involved getting the Norvik getting out
of the smaller place is just just not
taking one plane and hopping off and
you're there it's crazy travel that's
part of the adventure as you can see the
airplane has got significantly smaller
in size but we're that much closer to
getting the Norvik it's not like in any
other place where you can just you know
hop on an airplane and get to where you
need to be there's so many stops it's a
long process they started like that 3:00
in the morning for us it's almost noon
we're almost there they do some client
what's up brother yeah like why you
finally made it to Norvik we went from a
big plane or a small plane tons of gear
there's a lots of this show that goes on
behind the scenes just getting here is
part of the adventure
everything's a fight when it's 40 below
not only are we trying to keep ourselves
work I'm trying to keep our gear we're
very worried about four cameras freeze
enough to so right now I think two
warmers on the back of the stream and
insulating them and hopefully we can see
what we're doing that once the cameras
and equipment goes outside especially
lenses and cameras they have to stay
outside because when you bring them back
inside just the heat difference makes
conversation and the lens become useless
for at least a couple hours
so we're out here today filming Andy
doing a trapping we're in a slough we're
about four to six miles away from Eagle
and it's about negative twenty to thirty
degrees out here we survived we filmed
Rebecca that's my mom like controls all
the time just to get a little bit warm
get some warm tea have a drink or two
you know chill out today was so cold
that you know cables can snap things
like that so we're just glad we got
everything back in one piece we didn't
break anything